I'm Sebastian.
I come from Football Addicts.
We're a app company
from Gothenburg, Sweden.
We released an app
about two years ago
called Forza Football.
It's a football consumption app.
You can follow your
favorite teams and leagues
all over the world.
So this is my small agenda.
I'm going to go through
the challenges we
had with our design, which
we transitioned from.
And then I'm going to
show you some examples
of different views in our app
before we made a transition
to material design, and after.
So here is our app.
This is about a year ago.
It's the match list.
So you can see all the matches
that you're interested in.
It's a very tailored experience,
but right now is quite complex.
So a big part of this
transition to material design
is the overview.
So here it's a
bit hard, I think,
to find the cherries
that you would
like to get out of this view.
It's quite hard to
like get a short glance
of the small
things, and that was
a thing we wanted to change.
The navigation is really
important in any app of course,
but we have a lot of content,
a lot of data, and information.
So getting to the
information that you seek
is really, really important.
So we wanted to get
rid of the hamburger.
We've had a side
menu for a long time,
and we felt we needed to
refresh the navigation,
and make it flatter, and
more like easy to understand.
Like tap on what you want,
and then get it's immediately.
And yeah, I touched on content.
It's really important that
the content you care about
pops up, on your right
when you use the app.
Yeah, so here are
different screens
we had before we
did the redesign.
In the middle here,
we see the team page.
So I think it's
quite hard to-- we
made so many iterations of
different kind of design
standards.
So you can see a
little bit of both.
We have the IOS style toggle
button, which doesn't really
fit, I think.
And we have different colors.
We had some kind
of accent color,
but we didn't really know
what that meant back then.
And yeah, also
the league picture
with the flag and everything.
We wanted a more consistent
experience, and yeah.
So this is what we came up
with after the redesign.
We do realize that this
is a work in progress.
Like you're never done
with redesigning the app.
So, yeah, we can
always improve stuff.
But if we focus
on the match list,
we try to make each match
feel more important.
Like football consumers,
they care about results.
That should be the focus here.
We tried to reduce the size of
the-- tried to make it a more
compact navigation.
The hamburger is gone.
And yeah, we just tried
to make everything
more easy to understand,
and no get in your way.
And also the team pages,
and the league pages
right now are flying up,
and you can swipe them away
if you don't care anymore.
So I have some paper,
analogy going on there,
and the compressing
of the toolbar.
I could have a animation here
if I knew Google Sheets better,
but, yeah, you get
the point I think.
And we have pulled out
some of the key content,
the key information
about every team.
So we created card views of
all the things that we feel
are important.
But the major part
is, of course,
what the users
think is important.
So we need to test this
iterate, maybe move some card
views up and down.
But it's, as I said,
a work in progress,
and we try to use tests
as much as possible.
We're just getting
started with AVA testing
and stuff like that.
It's very new to us.
But, yeah, I really
like what they're
doing at Google right now with
the design libraries and stuff.
For example this sliding thing
and the compression of toolbar,
I think I put two or three
months of my work and time
on that.
But now you can do it in
like five lines of code
with the new design lip.
So thank you, Google, but,
yeah, too late for me.
Yeah.
That was it.